[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing voldemort
the gaunt family tom riddle senior and
love potions
more specifically we're going to be
discussing voldemort's relationship
with his mother father and trying to
decipher whether or not voldemort was
aware of the fact that his father
was a victim it certainly shouldn't be
news to anyone that voldemort hated his
parents
his mother unable to continue that the
love of his father
left young voldemort at wall's orphanage
shortly before
dropping dead she died of a broken heart
but from voldemort's perspective
the perspective of someone unable to
feel love she was a coward that
abandoned him
something that he would forever resent
her for
but voldemort's relationship with his
father wasn't so good either
you see when therapy was pregnant tom
riddle senior abandoned them
and traveled back to his home until
angleton he wanted nothing to do with
therapy
nor their unborn child as an adult
voldemort would commonly refer to his
filthy muggle father he even went as far
as changing his name
just so that he would no longer have any
association with him
you think i was going to use my filthy
michael father's name forever
i whose veins runs the blood of salazar
slytherin himself
through my mother's side i keep the name
of a foul
common muggle who abandoned me even
before i was born
okay so voldemort hated his father for
abandoning his mother
but one thing that i've always wondered
is did he know that his father was
actually a
victim in case you weren't aware maripi
gaunt developed an obsession with tom
middle senior
while they were both living in the town
of little hangalton
however rather than pursuing him by
traditional means
she instead concocted a love potion that
she gave to him
after drinking the love potion tom
riddle senior became infatuated with
merape
and it was after he drank the potion
that the two conceived a child
it wasn't until either a merripe stopped
giving it to him
or b that the potion simply wore off the
tom lil senior
finally realized his circumstance
fleeing home in order to get away from
the witch
that had tricked him i don't think you
can exactly blame him here
so my question is did voldemort know
this
would this change anything or would he
have killed and hated him
anyway first things first i think that
voldemort
immediately valued his mother over his
father regardless of any extenuating
circumstances
purely because he was a muggle and she
was a witch voldemort had it in his mind
essentially right from birth
that muggles were dirty and that only
pure blood witches and wizards
were worthy of well existence
however with that said i think if we pay
close attention to the following quote
to someone from earlier we should be
able to reasonably deduce that no
voldemort did not know that his father
was a victim
you think i was going to use my filthy
muggle father's name forever
i in whose veins runs the blood of
salazarin himself
through my mother's side i keep the name
of a foul
common muggle who abandoned me even
before i was born
just because he found out his wife was a
witch that last part just because he
found out his wife was a witch
sticks out to me because it reveals that
from voldemort's perspective
the only reason that tom riddle senior
left merripe was because her magical
heritage had been revealed
when in reality riddle senior left
maraby because he had realized that he
was the victim of a love potion
with all of that said however i'm not
sure that this would have made any
difference in his decision to kill his
father
nor would it have provided him with any
sympathy i say
this because voldemort was raised in an
era where men would have not typically
been viewed as potential victims
of this type of assault i think that if
voldemort became aware of what had truly
happened to his father
he would have hated him even more not
only would voldemort have seen him as a
filthy muggle
and a deserter he also would have seen
him as weak
what do you guys think did you ever
think about this let me know in the
comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live